all right Monty where you from wait
would you were you from originally
I'm from Spain you from Spain you came
to the United States at what agent Oh
about six months maybe
oh when you were yeah oh three did not
Los Angeles and you had both your
parents well there you see snow yeah but
growing up you had both your yeah we
started on as a family you know but
things happen yes did your parents
separate at some point
well my father died when I was two
oh my god pneumonia yeah one long left
so did you mom remarry or she remarried
unfortunately the wrong persons for her
but she had about two or three more
husbands and so how was your chocolate I
hoteles it was very young
religious I want you well Catholic
school for eight years
it's not there now but it was a from the
1st to 8th grade and your shop it was
good no abuse they like that well there
was some abuse whether they were wrong
run mostly by nuns and one nun in a
fifth grade she was the worst he was a
physical abuse actually
you know he would slap the pupils they
didn't turn fast enough or the ruler
will make him sit at the edge of a desk
you know punishment like that right no
no I didn't like it that was the only
thing I didn't like about the school
right was this trick nuns so later on
you went did you go to college I went to
Santa Monica City College okay
hey where'd you go where'd you graduate
though just had a couple of semesters
and how was your your work career did
you are you still working uh yes as a
matter of fact I am just uh temporarily
okay what did you do throughout your
career for jobs well um I went to the
Ranchester learned how to ride a horse
now and from there I went to uh a ranch
I won't buy all somebody from Arizona
Conway he trained he he raised horses
there then he trained him to God already
to go to the racetrack okay so uh I got
paid 25 a month and room aboard no and
there was 15 of us uh everybody had
their own room and they worked
throughout the ranch
training the horses and when he got
ready the trainer at the ranch would
sent him to the racetrack
so what other jobs does you have sure
later on I drove a bus for the RTD at
the time I was called RTD and I was
there both readers yeah after that I
went to Texas for a year and worked in
the house ii cook in other words I did
all the baking okay you know and they
were grooming me to be a first cook and
I was looking forward to that cuz I like
though like wood yeah yeah but you
didn't work out cuz I had to come back
here
my girlfriend was um out of trouble with
her baby and meningitis or something I
don't know anyways they needed me back
here thought I left and you kidding so
today you're working as as a high teen
apartment this is clean apartment yeah
temporary okay but it's money it helps
pay the bills
yes and the women are you're married yes
how many years have you been married
five years five years yeah and how old
are you me yes can you keep a secret
I can't well I mean I think did you'd
rather not say i won't i won't pressure
you to tell me your agent know you would
be surprised
i mean you you you look healthy your
hair is great i'm not really healthy I
uh I'm not a hundred percent in health
good health but I'm hanging in there you
know
I took a lot of drugs in mine you hungry
years oh you did no sorry both in but no
I know recognize them as a poison
and if the other people do it and are
using alcohol or drugs today
oh no why not I don't know
and dear children Oh as a matter of fact
I don't know children no and you're
married how many times I wasn't me twice
twice and what happened to your first
marriage how did that father it was
actually a shotgun wait what do you mean
well this I got this girl pregnant and
she told her mom and her mom threatened
me so I had a marry her just where's the
kids in name got it
so today you like to come down to skid
row and pick up some of the ladies that
work here yeah I don't I do uh you know
I look at it as you know I'm doing
myself a favor and limo favor you know
and uh you know sorry about that that's
the way I am right now
yeah it's the oldest what in the world
oh this yeah yeah professional efficient
yes so you'll come down how often well
three times a week three times a week
yeah and you'll go to your car or you go
to the hotel or where you go it depends
um what's the time I'll go to a small
hotel yeah there's a lot of cheap hotels
nearby yeah there's a favorite life is
called Oh
it's okay no your knees yeah yeah I know
I know though manager that her through
the drug train you know so well that's
all my ghetto break yeah
and have you had any better experiences
some of the girls will will kind of
trick the guys and rob them and some of
the guys will beat the women sometimes
I've heard both involve stolen for me
you know when I was in the restroom or
something you don't worry come on
they're gone yeah what about my wallets
gone yeah I don't know my listening yeah
and does your wife know that you did you
do this she suspects she suspects but I
don't come on and tell her I just you
know I let her suspect until she catches
the me in the end I just got a little
guess I'm gonna post this video on
YouTube there's a chance or your wife or
a friend of your wife might see this how
do you feel about that she would forgive
me he's not gonna go read more into it
to what I tell her you know I don't
think there's nothing nothing going on
it's perfectly fine you know so sure
sure
she'll believe this will be perfectly
fine cuz I'm getting cash you are and
I'm gonna bite our nice steak or
whatever you know do you see it as
something that you just kind of have to
do to remain happy and level-headed what
the just sex yeah
it satisfies me yes it does
I've been this way since I was growing
up you know there's some something
inside of man that makes him want to go
after a woman I don't know I forgot what
you call it but uh I have a thought of
it you're scaring sellers small to this
day I still you know he hasn't left me
right it's a blessing and a curse
yeah and so what kind of relationships
do you have with these women is it
purely just you know have sex or is it
sometimes well they know what I want I
know you know and I know what they offer
so most of them one repeats and that
helps a lot because I don't like to
start off from scratch yeah so you
establish the kind of trust
yeah right it just goes a long way yes
it does do use condoms are you safe when
you have sex with condoms yeah I don't
think that's important I don't
particularly like oh but it's safety
reasons yeah when I was growing up the
first intercourse was without a Jewish
lady she was downstairs at Barneys store
downstairs and uh always in the store
and the clerk says hey Bonnie want to
give her a hand with his groceries I
said sure
so it was a bar but right above the
store we went up to the store and uh
cause we oh 14 14 or 30
and uh by the way she she's helped me
with a box here put it up here it's not
helped her and that's how it started we
ended up in life in a bit
however she probably 38 4 and here you
are many decades later you're still at
it my first nice no remember yeah first
time is always memorable right and I
went there later because the
neighborhood kind of got wind of it I
went up there and there was five or six
guys up there you know drinking and
stuff like that and she was an invent
you know and then and then I heard say I
want our money on Monty I want you you
know and I want to stick around her you
know yes I like my privacy
yes so I just I don't even talk to her I
just took off but she was married a
woman do all an orderly or something he
both worked in a hospital that's how I
got to know her the first one I think
maybe this is more common than people
realize how many times people will stray
probably so yeah yeah I mean do you find
it helps keep your marriage together
what do you mean this mood for you I
mean you're currently married and having
these little things on the side yeah
well I bet I've always liked that and
how long as they can do it yeah a long
if she doesn't find out and you know
make a big deal about her yeah I'm
comfortable with it like I said she was
a stranger to me right and a lot of
these people I mean around here they
they start out as strangers - yes yeah
yeah a lot of the girls are actually
very nice right you get to know them in
there I all you deal with nice people
all right Monty well thank you so much
for being so open and sharing your story
okay I think you do awesome thank you
good
you